i mean it's okay to change their mind
because it's a novel virus and
and you learn new things what was
outrageous about it was
to treat the scientific inquiry as this
monolithic thing that's written in stone
and so if you go if you run afoul of it
then your voice needs to be censored
because frankly you don't
you're not following the science dave um
that's the attitude
and and also the fact that questions
that were ultimately
philosophical questions or policy
questions okay
we have this virus what degree of
restrictions is appropriate
are there other goods besides just
preserving life against the novel
coronavirus that we should preserve
those aren't scientific questions and
yet a kind of expert class
by trying to shoehorn it all into
they basically uh tried to
push their policy preferences and their
philosophical assumptions
as scientific claims which of course
they're not you know a
a statesman or a state's woman dealing
with something like the virus
has to weigh various things not just one
virus but also
other sources of threat to human life
like loneliness and depression
and and joblessness
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the op-ed editor
of the new york post and the author of
the unbroken
thread discovering the wisdom of
tradition in an age of chaos
saurabh amari welcome to the reuben
report
thank you dave thanks for having me i am
really glad to have you
and i read the book this weekend and i
really thought it was fascinating
because in
in many ways we come sort of from
different worlds sort of from a
different school of thought
but i think that the conclusions that
you came to in this book are very
similar to the conclusions
that i came to in my book that i think
ben shapiro has come around to you
actually reference him at the top of the
book
that jordan peterson has come to and uh
i mean i'm looking forward to chatting
with you but before we do anything i
know you wanted to address
the room that you're in right now you're
not being held hostage are you
yes not being held hostage not being
interrogated by some eastern european
police state it's just that i my my own
apartment
is um filled with rambunctious kids
so therefore a neighbor of mine is who
doesn't live in his own apartment really
so it's a kind of dilapidated place
is kind enough to let me use his place
hence the weird wire in the back
it's the best we can do under under
covered circumstances so bear with me
that is the story and you're sticking to
it and you are doing this
from new york city so you're in crazy
new york i'm in crazy la
how's life in new york right now i think
it's getting a little bit livelier
um the mask insanity is
you could see people not wearing mass
outside anymore which is a relief
um but you know as you know in terms of
crime
and disorder it's just growing yeah
so before we get into the specifics of
the book i'm curious what what really
made you
write the book and and really focus on
these 12
questions that we're going to we're
going to go through each one and discuss
each one
but what really brought you to this
conclusion that this book had to be
written now i mentioned to you right
before we started
that the subtitle in an age of chaos
that was about to be
in the subtitle of my next book and then
your book literally came across my desk
and we
changed it all together but but we are
in a time of chaos
yeah so in my case it's a book i wrote
for my son max he's now four years old
when i started writing it he was two
um and i'm really worried about the kind
of man that our
contemporary cultural political
arrangements will
chisel out of him he's named after a
great catholic saint who
is saint maximilian kolbe who is
was canonized and is famous for having
um chosen to die
in place of someone else at auschwitz
and
to me that uh his coal-based sacrifice
exemplified an account of freedom it's
really an
older account of freedom which defines
freedom as being willing to
limit yourself even unto death that
accepting limits accepting sacrifice
accepting duty and my fear is that my
max
if just left to our own culture will
inherit a very different account of
freedom
one that defines being free is just kind
of keeping your options open and
getting ahead in life in very
materialistic terms
and so my the book is my attempt to
tether my son
and hopefully maybe the reader to that
older
uh for lack of a better world trade word
traditional account of freedom
and the best way i can do that i'm not a
i'm not a philosopher a theologian i'm a
journalist and a storyteller
is to try to poke holes in some of our
contemporary certainties
and so i do that by posing 12 questions
that are either unasked or
that our age assumes have been
supplanted or made unnecessary that
science has basically
pushed them aside or what have you when
in fact they're still pertinent to what
it means to be
fully free fully human and then i
explore each of them through the life of
a
one great thinker um some of them kind
of
predictable maybe c.s lewis saint
augustine
but others will surprise readers because
you know they're
they're um not figures you typically
associate with the term
tradition and it's a kind of you know
it's a genre that i
invented in the sense that i pose these
questions and then i explore each um
through the narrative and the drama of
one life story
so the reader when he he or she reads it
will just um
will not be hit thick with philosophy
you're drawn into a story
and that's what propels each chapter
yeah and you end it really
on a nice note with a very short note to
your son
and what you hope the book has done so
let's talk about those
those 12 questions and you laid the book
out in two parts so part one which is
the first six questions
is the things of god part two is the
things of humankind so the first
question
is how do you justify your life and it
does seem to me right now
there is a huge amount of people
especially young people
that can't justify their lives so
they're acting out in all sorts of crazy
ways
right at their most most extreme they
say that if life is not worth passing on
in one way or another
um aoc um said some something
like that with respect to climate change
you know why would you put a child into
the world
um and that question really is a
critique
of of scientism not of science
which is a perfectly noble endeavor
that's unlocked lots of useful things
and
and helped unlock the mysteries of
really the cosmos and nature
but the attitude that would apply um
scientific the scientific outlook or the
scientific way of looking at the world
to the whole of life um and so
the reason i start with that question is
because i think a lot of
a lot of young people especially like
you said think
that because we know a lot about the big
bang
or cosmology uh
physic philosophy and and religion have
been
made superfluous you don't need
metaphysics anymore because
you know we have the big bang or we have
uh evolutionary theory
and uh you know what i argue and that
chapter is based on the life of c.s
lewis who was a great critic
of scientism in the 20th century is that
there are certain questions
uh about you know what's beauty or what
is beautiful why is something beautiful
why something ugly
what it means to be fully human what it
means to
to fall in love and so on and so forth
which don't have
they have right or wrong answers but
those right or wrong answers can't be
formulated using
facts which is the product of scientific
inquiry
and um so yeah i mean i i have to get
rid of scientism first if i'm writing
this book for my son
because he'll be bombarded with the idea
that uh you know
neil degrasse tyson has made aristotle
unnecessary yeah so of course you were
writing this during at least a portion
of the lockdown and
covid and everything else that's going
on and one of the things that we've seen
i think for the last year is just the
absolute
destruction of the elite class when it
comes to science
that people no longer trust the experts
because the experts
basically change their mind every week
for the last year and a half and that's
really no way to live
i mean it's okay to change their mind
because it's a novel virus and
and you learn new things what was
outrageous about it was
to treat the scientific inquiry as this
monolithic thing that's written in stone
and so if you go
if you run afoul of it then your voice
needs to be censored because frankly you
don't
you're not following the science dave um
that's the attitude
and and also the fact that questions
that were ultimately
philosophical questions or policy
questions okay
we have this virus what degree of
restrictions is appropriate
are there other goods besides just
preserving life against the novel
coronavirus that we should preserve
those aren't scientific questions and
yet a kind of expert class
by trying to shoehorn it all into
they basically uh tried to
push their policy preferences and their
philosophical assumptions
as scientific claims which of course
they're not you know uh
a statesman or a state's woman dealing
with something like the virus
has to weigh various things not just one
virus but also
other sources of threat to human life
like loneliness and depression and and
joblessness do you think we needed right
yeah yeah do you think we needed sort of
a philosopher class that could have been
working alongside the scientific class
to deal with this so we have a political
class
that works alongside of them but that we
really needed somebody else to discuss
those
issues i wouldn't put academic philos
i majored in philosophy and i obviously
i'm a a kind of
amateur lover of philosophy so as but i
wouldn't put philosophers in charge i
think ultimately it has to be
statesmen and states women and and uh
you know elected bodies because that's
how our government works
but it would it would have been nice to
have had
not just dr fauci but ethicists and
and bioethicists and and other people
who would who would
and and frankly uh you know pastors and
religious
figures because that's an important
dimension of human life if they were all
in form and then a statesman
chooses from among them rather than
elevating one
form of knowing one form of knowledge
which is perfectly legitimate in its own
realm
and making it into the sort of uh idol
where and if you cross it then you're
you're against science
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out
our full episode playlist they're all
right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell